Oh everybody uses the terms values and
culture you know values is kind of a
statement of what's supposed to be
important around here and it's usually
kind of the something that's very well
crafted something that people take a lot
of time with and something that is the
ideal that people really want to aspire
to it's what's important but also by
implication what's not important and if
it works it's kind of a guide to inform
the tactical and strategic decisions
that the company is involved with
culture on the other hand is the
character of the organization
it's what everybody knows about how
things get done and what's important and
they're not necessarily the same the
culture is pervasive in every nook and
cranny of work life you know the values
is usually either on a you know inside
of a picture frame in the lobby or
sitting on a coffee mug on the table but
culture is actually what happens every
day values is talking the talk and
culture is walking the walk and when
they're inconsistent with each other of
course everybody gets very cynical about
what's in the value statement I think
when you talk about culture that the
buck stops here it culture flows from
the top down culture flows from the CEO
down have to do with all the decisions
that get made from day to day which is
an expression of values in the company
how the organization works the process
is really an example to people as they
go forward the character of the people
involve the personality of the people
involved I speak to that you know when
the CEO is a kind of a you know subdued
kind of pessimistic down kind of person
it kind of permeates the organization it
becomes part of the culture same is true
when they're kind of optimistic or even
reckless sometimes yeah a new CEO equals
a new culture think back in your
experience I don't know if any of you
have experienced an environment where
the CEO changed in an organization when
the CEO changes the culture changes on
the same day if the cultures are very
close sometimes it's hard to see where
the the CEOs are very different the
cultures changes very sharply in the
first day you know everybody already
comes to work they look at the new
person running the company and they
start saying well what are the signals
I'm getting
how things done around here and what's
important and etcetera etcetera so it's
really you know culture is kind of the
result of the leadership and the style
and the character of the person involved
in the company I think that the kind of
the the meta message the message that I
kind of like to think about in terms of
leadership is the difference between
proprietorship and stewardship
proprietorship is I believe these are
very fundamental is a very kind of
pervasive fundamental issue issues of
leadership style proprietorship is about
me and about what you can do for me
today it's my company I own this thing
you know it's I'm doing this stuff etc
it said our stewardship is about us and
about what we can build together for the
future and stewardship has that kind of
implication of somebody coming you know
beyond you rather than it kind of living
and dying with you so I think we're
priced so stewardship is really kind of
my view of what great leadership is
about it's about this mental set on the
part of the leader that this is a this
is an exercise in stewardship rather
than leadership so given that brief
introduction let me kind of jump into
what I think are the issues of
leadership it's this is and I should
kind of put it in the context of as I
was the CEO of Veritas for I was
actually a CEO from 1980 through through
the year 2000 and CEO for 20 years and
as I kind of progressed in the job you
know the first time I had the job of CEO
is kind of like well they see I remember
what CEOs were like in my past
I'll do the things that I like that they
did and I'll and I'll do differently the
things I didn't like that they did and
might and my kind of idea of leadership
at that time was kind of leadership
experience prime it's everything I
experienced you know kind of plus my
variation thereof well 20 years is a
long time it gives you an opportunity to
do a lot of thinking about things and
certainly as Veritas grew leadership
change is different you know being the
leader of 25 people and it is you know
2,500 people and I would say I spent a
great deal of time thinking about this
and and I think
I am very proud actually of not only
what we did as a company in terms of
results but I'm actually very proud when
you know I have children that live in
the area don't chosen to live in the
area whenever they run into someone you
know from Veritas when I was there it's
a great company great management great
leadership not political you know a
happy place for people to work and
that's kind of when they hear that that
makes me happy and proud right I mean so
so that's kind of the was the end result
of that so let me talk about this the
first thing I have here is a view of
leadership from Charles de Gaulle when I
want to know what France thinks I
question myself and I would kind of put
that in the category of not something
that we is consistent with the style we
want on the other hand if I look at you
know Taoism Lao to it leader is best
when people barely know that he exists
when his work has done his aim is
fulfilled they will all say we did it
ourselves those are I mean I kind of
went through all these little quotes
that you have and you know these these
leadership in these quote books you know
and look these are the two the the
opposite extreme if I could describe it
that way so let me talk about you know
some of the issues that I experienced be
visible and be invisible it's
interesting thing that a large part of
of being a leader is being visible to
the people around you that you know
there's an old we haven't it's not like
it's not in the vernacular anymore they
used to always say at HP the management
styles it was MDW a management by
walking around so you go out and you
talk to people and you make sure that
they see you and you see them in
addition to interpersonal meetings
there's a lot of public meetings there's
a lot of there's a lot of very visible
things you do as a manager I think it's
important to be accessible I remember
when you know at Veritas when we we
built our building I said you know they
said where do you want your office to be
and I said well you build you lay out
the whole building and our first
building you like the whole building and
I'll tell you where I want to go they
laid out the whole building and I said
okay so this location here which is you
know near the conference rooms and the
coffee stops and the stairs and this is
a place where you're gonna have the
maximum amount of public traffic up of
my office right there
with glass walls on it and no I didn't
have an assistant for many years
so people would walk by and they'd see
me and my door was open and they'd walk
in and I'd say how are things going and
whatever they were doing and it was just
every day I probably saw you know 30
people just to come in just just when I
was doing working in my office it'd be
invisible and the invisible part is the
interesting part it's the real work of
leadership is done behind the scenes and
out of sight and and and often alone I
think that leadership my definition of
leadership is creating an environment
where people can independently apply
their intellect judgment and energy who
advance the vision and goals of the
organization and to achieve a personal
sense of accomplishment of their work so
that's kind of what I describe as the is
what leadership is and the in red it
says creating the environment so yet sit
down and think about you know every day
and you know in the actions you take
every day well does this create the
environment that meets those goals or
does it not and that's the work that's
not visible to anybody and that's the
work that's actually very difficult you
know when I take this action when I do
this when I make this decision when I
whatever does it for further these
things there's a created environment
where you get great people to come where
they use their intellect their judgment
their capability that's what you're
hiring them for they forward the mission
and and they get a sense of
accomplishment and share I get a shared
sense of ownership in the outcome this
is a very very difficult thing to do if
you think about how you create an
environment it's a it's a very amorphous
or a difficult it's very you know there
aren't like 14 steps that you can go put
one in front of the other and say
there's your answer it's not management
management is accomplishing complex
tasks through others this really has
nothing to do with that this says that
when you have all these marriages
working for you they work correctly
consistent with that environment
glamorous is the opposite of leadership
I think that it's you know it's not
about me
there's a lot of things to do that are
glamorous in the business but as a
leader you're actually always thinking
of others and putting them first you
know you can be a comrade to your
followers but you can never be one of
them I always like the you know the
Henry v you know Shakespeare and he kind
of goes out and walks them
the troops before this great battle that
they're going into you know and you
sense his his low you know although he
can go talk to these with you sense how
how apart he is from you know from
everybody involved there when you're
doing clamorous things you're just doing
your job and this team it's an
interesting thing I was you know in
Veritas I was a public company I was
always on CNN after earnings
announcement as most CEOs are of
companies that are interest to the
public and I used to you know you I
don't know it it seems more glamorous
than it is but I used to get up and they
used to have a song like around you know
five o'clock in the morning so I have to
get up at like 3:30 you know get dressed
and everything and it was often times
actually on Stanford campus or down that
and you go to this little black room and
just one person over there and you're on
CNN you know and all these people call
you you know these people that you knew
from third grade
hey but it's easy to get carried away
with you know that hey I'm a you know a
little you know fifteen minute celebrity
right and I used to think about that and
put it in the context of you know me
doing this the right now is really no
different than the programmer that's
sitting in his office three o'clock in
the morning by himself working on
something it's the same thing I'm just
doing my thing for the company he's
doing his thing for the company and that
kind of perception of it that kind of
you know kind of view of things I think
is kind of takes the glamour it takes it
makes you understand that you're all
part of our team you're just doing the
thing that you do for the team rather
than not warning of danger this is a
warning glamour is seductive it's
seductive it's easy to you know you get
invited to banker conferences and you go
to Davos and you know you start thinking
you're a real celebrity and I'm telling
you it's very seductive and it's very
very hard to kind of keep your sense of
yourself about you as a some humility
and some kind of I'm the same as
everybody else it's very seductive so if
you're loyal to one you're loyal to none
a leader has to be loyal to the mission
above all else
you can't really have friends and
favorites inside the company it is one
of the things that kind of makes you
more alone than other people in the
organization you are responsibility for
the well-being of all the people and
you're the keeper of fairness and equity
in the organization if you have
favorites if you express biases towards
certain people and against other people
in a in a personal way it's something
that is very distorting and very bad for
the organization I have an interesting
you know kind of interesting way that I
used to think about this that the guy
who built Veritas with me a person who
I'm extremely close to you know we you
build a company like that together with
someone and you you build great bonds
with them there is not a doubt in my
mind that if he was not doing the right
thing for the company that I would ask
him to leave there's not a doubt in my
mind that if I was not doing the right
thing for the company he would go to the
board and get me removed and because of
our value system neither one of us would
have it any other way we both were very
much in line with this idea that you do
the right thing for the organization
above all else and as long as they were
always pulling their weight that's
that's that's that's fine if they're not
you go make the changes you have to it
also goes to you know to the extent that
you as I said you know everything starts
from the top down to the extent that you
have favorites and you create a
political environment I promise you
it'll go through the organization other
people will kind of have favorites as
well and little it'll kind of infect the
organization the further you are from
the problem the less you know about it
trust those on the front lines they
really do know more than the people back
home at the Home Office the first line
manager knows less about the specifics
and the next manager knows even less and
you know when you get to the top which
we all ascribe to you really don't know
anything about anything and that's true
you you have no knowledge you know you
know we used to talk about you're in a
company you have a customer situation
it's the salesman and the first-line
manager that know what's going on there
that you know you can sit and
hypothesize and make things up in your
mind but you really have no idea what's
really going on and
frontlines and the development
organizations and the finance
organizations so you really don't know
anything about anything more so what you
really want to do is you want to trade
your situational knowledge which is now
at zero for judgment experience in
perspective and what we used to do at
Veritas whenever we had to make
decisions we used to get to people who
knew what was going on involved in the
decisions so if we had a customer
decision we'd get the sales rep on the
phone in a conference call if it was
like a big corporate decision about a
deal or something like that for two
reasons one we wanted his information
and number two we want to know how he
feels about living with the outcome and
we want to get him engaged in this and
people really had a you know a sense of
that being of them being able to control
the things that were had input into the
things that were important to them was a
very important you know kind of
dimension of the company the higher up
you get the fewer decisions you should
make so everyone offers your decision I
I have to tell you you know I remember
that little public space I described
where I used to sit well one of the
things that happened is that people used
to coming all day long and asked me you
know should we do a or B I'll give you
an example they'd come in and they'd say
we're having a Christmas party we can't
decide whether we got to have a parfait
or a pastry for dessert so look I'm not
good you know it's funny but I'm telling
you it's what goes on they walk into
your office and say you know we don't
know what you know we kind of have this
discussion we should we have a parfait
or or a pasty for dessert that's the
kind of the trivial example but there's
lots of other examples that seem more
sophisticated but are in fact equally
trivial so what you want to do is you
want to say what's the impact of this
decision you know have the people
involved thought about it are they more
or less in the right quadrant and what's
the downside here and you know the very
very large majority of decisions in an
organization have been thought about
there are more or less than right
quadrant and the downside is not great
the larger majority the you know 95th
95% or something like this be very very
very large number and you know allowing
others to make the decision has real
meaning to them so they come in and they
ask me for the dessert you know and I
say well you know you guys are planning
this whole thing you know what are you
think and they kind of say well I say
you know why don't you guys decide what
you want to do it's you sound completely
competent you're more thoughtful about
thoughtful about this than I am and you
don't have to come and tell me the
answer you don't have to report back to
me you know and people like that you
know they kind of walk out of my office
they get a little spring in their step
they're kind of an inch taller and they
go home when they tell her stuff yeah
you know I went into the CEO and I said
you make the decision right you know
people like that and it's an important
ingredient in getting them engaged in
the company and it teaches them how to
make decisions and it teaches them to
not be afraid to make decisions you
can't when you run a large organization
you can't make decisions for everybody
you have to get people to make decisions
and you have to give them to make good
ones so you know this is a you know the
fewer decisions you make the better it
is and and and it's not an abrogation of
your job you know that the idea of the
CEO kind of sitting at the command
console and making decisions and
pressing but it's it's not the way you
build the culture it's you know it's the
way you micromanage and you know who
wants to work in a place like that the
more power you give away the more you
have the you empower individuals by
giving them knowledge authority and an
acceptable margin of error what I know
that you don't know makes me more
powerful than you so what you want to do
is you want to level that playing field
a leader has the power to do this a
leader has the power to take the
information that is in organizations
tends to be you know held at higher and
higher levels and tell everybody you
know you can tell people more than you
think you can let me give an example of
this but and it diminishes to put the
politicization of the organization let
me give an example of giving away power
and and kind of the results of it we had
in early and veritas we had a problem
where we're sitting around the executive
staff meeting we said you know we really
have too many shares we have you know a
capital structure we had you know a
company of 25 people and we had 30
million shares outstanding we had more
millions of shares and we have employees
it's not a good thing
we hire people we give them stock
options we give them these big numbers
and Sunday we're going to pull
rug out from under them because we're
gonna reverse split this stock and it
doesn't feel good to me you know it
doesn't feel like a you know like we're
kind of having a straight deal so you
know we talked about this at the staff
meeting and the kind of the thought was
well why don't we do it three for one we
were split and then you know all the all
the pushback was you know
oh yeah everybody's gonna be demoralized
oh buddy's gonna hate management they're
gonna think they're getting screwed and
all this other stuff so I said well
listen why don't we just give them all
the information let them make the
decisions now I don't know how many
company you know that we'd go to the
employee base and say do you think we'll
reverse split the stock but I can't
think of any besides you know my story
over here so we go to the employee base
it looked you know not a lot different
than this it wasn't teared up but it was
about the same number of people I walked
into the room holding a ten dollar bill
and I said does anybody have two fives
of course everybody is very suspicious
at this point in time because they don't
know what's happening
nobody gives me I said come on is
anybody have two five so we kind of
found somebody to do a little you know
change for ten and I said before you put
it away would you mind if we exchange it
back and they said no I said so you're
kind of indifferent whether you have one
ten or two fives and they say yeah and I
said great we're here to discuss a
reverse split today which is a
completely perfect analogy to that so I
said look we think that it's a problem
well that we have too many shares
outstanding and we hire people if we
give them you know this kind of improper
information I don't care cuz I do the
math I kind of do the I do things in
percentages so it makes no difference to
me whether we have three million shares
or three hundred million shares I said
but most employees come in and they say
well if I get so many shares times a
hundred dollars this is what it's going
to be worth something in the future
right so we think we gotta kind of for
the sake of being you know it's going to
happen eventually we think we've got to
do it sooner rather than later and so
and then I said but you know what since
you guys seem to care about this a lot
we're gonna let you make the decision
and anything you want to do is okay with
us so we gave them a lot of information
we spent a lot of time talking they had
a lot of questions you know what kind of
went on and on I my experience from that
was that that software nothing software
engineers like more than software except
financial engineering love financial
engineering love
about stock options so we did all this
other stuff you know and and they're
very sophisticated so we did all this
and I said you know we're not ready to
make a decision why don't we kind of
chew on this for a week and instead of
working and we'll kind of meet up here
next week and make a decision so they
kind of can't you know how to parade of
people in my office asking questions and
week later they voted the big objection
they had was well if we hire someone new
and our stock option is smaller than
someone else's won't we lose that person
and I said well you will unless you
explain what you now know so they can go
ask the right questions to the other
company and if they and and if we're the
ones that educate them and give them
this understanding in fact we will have
the credibility and trust they all kind
of nod their head and voted unanimously
to do it it was a very interesting
experience because the management team
didn't want to do this the management
team thought we should not give them you
know they kind of offer them this
decision two things that came out of it
were very interesting one that came out
of it was we came you know we the
conclusion was is that these people when
you give them all the information
actually come to the right conclusion
for the right reasons which was you know
a great thing to experience and from the
employee point of view I can assure you
and you can probably relate to this that
if we had came into the room and given
him exactly the same information in
exactly the same amount of detail and
then we've told him that this is a
decisions management was making every
single one of them would have walked out
and said there's something I don't know
there's something they're not telling me
and I'm getting screwed here and this
way they walked out saying you know I
like this it's a fair deal I have all
the information and I had control of
this thing so I really believe you give
away information and you the more power
you give away the more you have those
people become loyal those people become
they enhance the ability of the company
to do things and I think it actually
cruised to the power of the leadership
power and in a positive sense empowered
individuals to be loyal to the company
and loyal to the leadership okay so know
thyself we all want to know everything
and be best at everything it's a
hallmark of great leaders that they know
their strengths weaknesses likes and
dislikes I would suggest that you want
to augment your weaknesses with other
people's strengths you
to be able to first of all do a fair
inventory but you want to go you know
the things that you're not good at hire
people who are better at it way better
out of that you are and give them the
opportunity to do that possible find
other spoons of things you don't like we
all have things we don't like to do you
know I'm completely capable of sitting
in a meeting doing an Operations review
on action items you know meeting every
Monday morning for three hours to do
that but I gotta tell you to me it feels
like someone's sticking toothpicks under
my fingernails it's very painful for me
to do that so I don't do that so I run a
company I hire people to go like to do
that there's people who love doing this
stuff right I saw I hire people to go do
the things I don't like to do check to
see if your self-assessment is is shared
by others trust and you will be trusted
it's this is a again this is a more of a
demeanor than it is a kind of a
mechanism so the first level of trust is
based on Fairplay that is visibly
exercised so fair play is how do you
compensate people how do you promote
people how do the process of the
companies work but great leadership
comes from a deep sense of trust between
the leader and the lead as a leader I
believe you have to trust first I
believe you have to express trust before
you can expect to be trusted you may
occasionally get this appointed but I
think the payoff is far greater than the
cost Trust is giving people information
Trust is saying you know this is
information that's confidential to the
company and we share it with you because
you're part of the company and we expect
you not to share it with other people
and occasionally you get disappointed
but I think that they that the take is
much but much much much greater than
they give in that situation confront
issues directly but be thoughtful
gracious and caring there are a lot of
difficult things you do when you you
know run any kind of large organization
you have to fire people you have to
negotiate very difficult deals you have
to you know go after competition
whatever sometimes you have to do a RIF
I think it's important to do all things
with caring and grace I think it's
really important to treat people with
dignity and each person you meet and to
kind of have that as a stylistic thing
to do is there's nothing whatever it is
you're doing
nothing you know there's really nothing
personal here and it really behooves you
to kind of be as I say gracious caring
and a kind person in the things you do
and you know for the for those of you
who want to have a reason for a non
altruistic reason for doing it you never
know where you gonna meet these guys
again so I learned this had a little
personal experience as a young Sales
Manager I was interviewing this guy and
you know five minutes into the interview
was clear that this guy was like a
turkey right so you know being uncaring
and ungracious I proceeded to let him
know that in the interview by asking him
questions that I knew he couldn't answer
it was really an awful experience and so
I kind of didn't think much about it we
ended up I you know cut the interview
short as I could and left the room and
about two weeks later he shows up but
one of my customers is the VP of Sales
it was just awful it was just an awful
experience so you never know what you're
gonna run into these people again I have
in my career in in these kinds of things
and for business reasons for the right
business reasons I have a friend who I
hired and fired and then three years
later hired and fired you know there's a
long story no good reasons but you know
we're still friends because we were able
to kind of go past those things in a way
that you know I was went out of my way
to be is it's caring and as gracious as
I could the whole truth the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
one of my favorites here a key job of
management is to fix broken stuff if you
don't know what's broken you can't fix
it and everybody wants to tell you what
they think you want to hear what they
think you want to hear they think you
want to hear good news and happy
happiness and in a way that will make
them look good so here's the great news
and I'm the guy that that's bringing it
to you you have to find a way to
convince people that you need to know
the truth and if you can't convince
people this you're not going to know the
truth and you have to always honor the
message messenger this you have to when
people
and tell you something that's you know a
disaster going on thank you for telling
me this is the something that is really
important for this company to know and I
now I can act on it and you have to
really kind of give them a sense of
having done a good deed for doing this I
have a great story
you guys like stories yeah okay so I
have a great story that goes with this
in 1999
Veritas had prior prior you know you're
a year and a half early entered the
backup business but by 1999 the artisan
ligado were locked in a head-to-head
battle on every backup deal in the
marketplace and it was you know it's
just it was a it was a two company you
know kind of brutal you've seen this
before two companies every single deal
both have kind of you know great
offerings you know they're a little
different but it's like everybody in you
know Veritas is crush legato and
everybody got Ellis crush Veritas it was
you know just one of those kind of had
to head things
so naturally the end of the first
quarter I I called up the not naturally
but at the end of the first quarter I
called up our sales department I said I
want an inventory of every single deal
that we went head-to-head with legato I
want to know who won the deal and I want
to know how much how much money changed
hands on the deal you know because they
know what happened if they lose a deal
because of a discount they usually know
so we kind of tell you all that up and I
look at all the numbers and we had made
our quarter I look at all the numbers
and I said I think they mr. core you
know you know I had all the data right I
think I had all the data so I called up
my board and I sent an email to my board
I said you know I think they missed a
quarter and sure enough they an asset
quarter everything is hunky-dory quarter
two we go for the same you know the same
exercise we look at this stuff
quarter three the same exercise I'm
sitting there saying like are they
selling this stuff on Jupiter I can't
figure out where they're selling this
stuff I have no idea what's going on
quarter four comes along same thing
happens we kind of tally up all the
stuff and we say look they have to miss
a quarter quarter four comes along they
say we're not ready to announce yet we
have some accounting issues that we have
to go through
and we think we missed quarter four
two weeks later they said yes we missed
quarter four actually in this quarter
one quarter two and quarter three also
and the question is this how come I knew
and the CEO I know the CEO of that
company is a good guy how come I know
and he didn't know well he didn't know
because he didn't ask the questions and
he didn't kind of build the clarity of
communications in the organization I
remember you know we actually tried to
merge with this company number years ago
I remember always going over to his
office and I would go into his office
when I go into the executive section and
then I go into the back of the executive
section and I go past as his assistant
and I finally get to this little corner
office that you know probably nobody had
ever been into besides him he was a guy
that really isolated himself from the
organization and that's the price he
paid it was a very you know there was it
was a very you know definitely new
management you know board had to change
everything was really an awful situation
but it is the perfect example of you
know let's hear the bad news sooner
rather than later if they had if they
had known in q1 what was going on and
they had announced it and remediated it
nobody would have gotten fired you know
things happen you miss a quarter
occasionally and they would have been
able to go rebuild from there so the
consequences were really dire in that
situation listen to everyone but trust
your own judgment you know that may
sound a little bit in conflict with some
of the things I say but you know there's
kind of a principle of of you know you
do have experience you do have common
sense when you kind of listen to a lot
of things and they kind of don't seem to
make sense to you they probably are not
sensible so you kind of have to kind of
as the world passes by as this kind of
stream of information and decisions and
process goes by you have to kind of keep
yourself grounded in kind of sensibility
be open be genuinely open listen
constructively learn I think you want to
hold your opinions close to yourself you
know hold your opinions in abeyance and
not kind of jump to conclusions but at
the end of the day I think you have to
trust your own judgment mostly if you do
a great job of building a great
organization and giving them you know
that creating that environment I talk
about mostly what's going on as a be
good we're going to be consistent with
your judgement so it's really not a
problem but there are times
when you have to kind of step away and
say you know doesn't make sense me
whether we're to think about this a
different way there's life after death
you know every company particularly
entrepreneurial companies will have
black days and I mean black days that
are so black that you think that there
is no tomorrow that you think you have
you look death in the face anybody in a
small company or anybody have a black
day so far yeah every company has black
days they're awful I mean they are
psychologically they are you know you
have a knot in your stomach it's it's
just it's just an awful thing to
experience but it's part of it part of
the deal everyone as the leader of the
company will be looking at you and you
know you need to communicate candidly
and directly become and show them a
little bit of light at the end of the
tunnel focus on the things you can do to
make a difference and mostly the
opportunity here is overcome adversity
overcoming adversity together bills
forges teamwork and Trust and I have a
story it's a good story we'll do another
story and I think we have time yeah so
Veritas was Veritas was at when public
in December of 1993 it actually with
today be considered a micro IPO the we
raise 16 million dollars in the IPO and
the company and market cap when we're
done with 64 million that would be a
nano IPO actually
anyway and we have and the year prior we
had finished ten million dollars at
profitable profitable operations so we
have four quarters of profitability it
was very solid company but small so we
went public and that's December of 1993
and we're in first quarter of 1994
probably around two-thirds through the
quarter and the quarter is about you
know a little over two million dollars
we did ten million a year before it's
kind of fourth quarter loaded so ten
million dollars about two to point to a
million dollars in a quarter and I'm
away at Point Reyes with my wife and my
aunt and uncle who are in from out of
town and I'm up there you know and I'm
checking my you know I have my cell
phone with me I've checked my you know
checking all the time I get this message
and around 11 o'clock that this deal we
have with Mentor Graphics for $300,000
they call us up and said they're
canceling the deal and they're shutting
down a project and this was the deal
that you know we had had we've probably
worked on we were doing some custom work
for it probably work on this thing for
like you know 15 months so 300,000 out
of you know 2.2 do the math right
there's no way we can make the course
this is Friday afternoon so some of you
will be able to relate to this so so
here it is 11 o'clock I'm out I can't I
can't leave these guys my wife and my
aunt and uncle I had nothing I can do
except you know call in every five
minutes to see if there's any more news
which of course there isn't
I have this knot in my stomach and I
spend the rest of the day I'm in a
silent movie they're all talking to each
other
I have no idea what's going on I have
put on sitting there you know dwelling
on this thing you know and it's awful
right and you know the the great news is
this is really a kind of a moment for me
where I really learned something
the great news was it was Friday
afternoon I was out of the office and I
didn't have time to react so I had a
time had an opportunity to think about
it and I went home with thought about it
over the weekend and and and I thought
about the fact that you know it's more
important what the outcome of the
process is less important the outcome is
less important than the process what
what we do as a company and how we deal
with this adversity it is more important
than whether we miss the quarter or not
interestingly enough that's a hard thing
to kind of figure you know when you're
staring in the face of this blackness
it's hard to figure it's hard to do this
so I walk in in the morning you know I
go to the staff meeting it's a small
company I don't know we got 50 people in
the company nothing travels faster the
bad news everybody knows I walk in
there's all these you know everybody
everybody what are they looking at
they're looking at me right so everybody
walks in they're looking at me we go to
staff meeting and it's really bleak and
I said you know so so look I said this
is a disaster this is a catastrophe
this is awful I said you know this is
just as black a day as we can have I
said now it turns out we deserve to get
this cancels because we did a terrible
job on this project and you know all
along was problematic and they actually
made the right decision to cancel this
thing and it's it's really good to speak
truth in a meeting like this everybody
knew that was the truth but you know and
I said so we'd have to do a post-mortem
on this we have to figure out how we
messed up and what the issues are I said
but I think if we do it right now we're
gonna be very emotional and I don't
think we're gonna be trying to you know
fix the blame instead of fix the problem
so I want to put a moratorium on that
and I want to not not do this you know
there's post mortem until a month has
gone by so we can all calm down however
we thought that was a good idea and I
said so it looks like we have a $300,000
problem and this
this deal was with Mentor Graphics up in
up in Portland and I said so does
anybody have any ideas what we can do
and they're looking at me pretty much
the way you're looking at me right now
nobody had an idea it was kind of a
bunch of blank faces you know and and I
kind of let that sit for a while and I
raised my head I said well I have an
idea and they said well great what's
your idea so I said well I think we got
to do is I think we got to go to Mentor
Graphics and we are asking for hundred
thousand dollars and they said they just
cancelled the contract I said yeah I
know that I said but it is a contract
you know we did more bad things and they
did but they did bad things too as all
contracts when they kind of come to an
end have a bad you know bad on both
sides however I think we gotta go and
say we do have a contract we are someone
company we are vulnerable we just went
public why don't you guys give us a
hundred thousand dollars I want we have
a clean walk away from this thing I was
sitting there nodding head and I turn
around to the guy who owned the account
and I said you know come of the
executive on account I said you think
you could go convince him of that he
said I think I could I said great you
don't have to stay for the rest of the
meeting you need to leave here get on an
airplane go to Portland and call me when
you after you spoken to someone call up
and let us know what's going on so so he
left the room and now we have a two
hundred thousand dollar problem which is
pretty good I said anybody else have any
ideas so the the sales manager said you
know we got this deal sitting out in
London and we probably could you know we
could probably discount and bring it
into the quarter if we had to I said
well who's the routes the sales guy and
then he said well Peter I said Cole
Peter in a room so Peters a sales rep
but he had no appointments to this
particular day so he came into the room
flip-flops short pants unshaven you know
like he was just gonna hang around the
office and do a little work during a day
it's a very informal company and so we
said so Peter this deal that we have at
ICL I said I said I said Peter you know
the problem he said yes I said this deal
that we have it ICL you think you can
pull it into the corner he said I think
so I said you don't have to stay for the
rest of the meeting
yeah I said you have your passport with
you he said I do I said why don't you
pack up your briefcase head to the
airport and go to London and he said
okay and on his way to the airport he
calls his contact in London he said hey
I'm coming in to talk to you guys about
a deal I don't have any place to sleep I
don't have any clothes and how many
toiletries could help me out and they
said sure you know and he went and slept
at the guys house and he called me the
next day and you know we we ended up to
175 K deal so now we had 275 we had 25
to go and I said anybody having ideas
and we you know we kind of found some
what we call pots and pans you know some
little pieces of you know five K here
and 2 K there and we kind of got over
the top it was a great experience for
the company it was an experience where
we didn't fix the blame we fixed a
problem people work together we felt you
know we built trust we built teamwork we
faced adversity together it was a great
it was a great experience and for me it
was an eye-opener it was the first time
you know it's not you know you don't you
don't you don't point fingers you know
you know you you look at it as an
opportunity
it is a leadership opportunity you look
at it and say you know they're gonna be
good days and bad days when bad days
come what can I do to build more
teamwork in the company what can I do to
build more cohesiveness more sense of
overcoming adversity you don't always
come overcome all that you can always do
something about it right and doing
something together makes a difference it
was a great it was a great personal
experience for me the other side of that
is when things are great remind people
they'll be dark days again because
promise you they will be I mean there
always will be in the future right
only those are both paranoid and
courageous will survive this is kind of
paraphrased from from Annie Grove only
the paranoid survive you never know
where and how the world might change and
great companies make transformational
changes you have to put your whole
company at risk sometimes in order to
save it my it is it is the it is the
character I believe is the character
that company's very successful companies
kind of go up this slope the world
changes slowly during that time at some
point in time their product or market or
whatever it is changes to the point
where growth slows down and kind of
flattens
and then kind of slowly flattens more
and it ultimately goes down slowly and
it's easy not to see that it's easy
either not to see that or it's easy to
say we'll grow this load and you know
we're a great company and da-da-da-da-da
it is the character of transformational
there's character great companies that
they go up this slope they flatten out a
little bit and they find a new slope to
go and they do that by transformation
and I have you know some some some
stories Intel was you know since since
Andy groves quote Intel for those of you
who remember long enough used to be in
the memory business with everybody else
the memory business was just a tough
business in the semiconductor business
but it was said that if he weren't in
the memory business you couldn't keep
your process competitive so everybody
had to be in the memory business and
Intel raise their hand one day and said
we're getting out of the memory business
we're gonna be only in the processor
business and we're gonna keep our
process good in the processor business
and everybody said it was a disaster
together the memory business even though
it was a commodity business they would
lose their process they would lose her
edge and they basically transformed
themselves from one among many to the
world's leading company you know which
they had the dominance in for decades as
a result of that decision was a very
very courageous decision you know
Microsoft was a was a was a know am
supplier to IBM they became an OEM
supplier to the world in operating
systems they built multiple businesses
on top of that they built their office
business they built their they built
their their database and Mail business
they they have you know done a great job
of continuing to find new things to
build a company over time rather than
trying to let one kind of do that son
was a was a was a scientific work
station company and converted themselves
into a commercial server company that's
a pretty pretty far away conversion to
get from one to the other HP over its
history went from being an instrument
company to being a computer company to
being a printer company if you kind of
look at you know kind of look at the
persona of the company and Oracle went
from being a database company to an
applications company it's the great
companies that have the ability to kind
of go find new things new markets new
opportunities and transform the company
and oftentimes you have to put the
company at risk to do that
a lot of people who are going to tell
you that you're wrong and that these
things are too risky and you need the
courage to stay the course there is no
finish line one of my one of many of
these are in favorites of mine this is
one of mine
building a crate company is like
building a cathedral those who start
hopefully will not see its you know you
see its completion and each
accomplishment is a prelude to the next
challenge
so we have and it kind of goes together
with the last slide the last slide says
you know you have to go transform
yourself but it kind of speaks to the
fact that there is no resting place you
know when you're running a business and
in a competitive marketplace each day
you accomplish something and each day
there's a new challenge in front of you
and you have to run fast and be
competitive but there's no place where
you can go and arrest and I have this
used to have this picture in my mind
it's kind of a I don't know how you
describe it you know it's you know maybe
it's a daydream or what everybody is to
see myself going you know trudging up
this you know kind of very very steep
mountainous area and everybody in the
company was doing this with me right
we're all going up there together and we
get to this plateau this you know Mesa
and everybody feel great you know it's
time to rest and time to set up camp and
time to you know build tents and get
water and eat and all these other things
and I get to there and the only thing I
could see is the next mountain I would
cook at it it would fill my eyes and I
turn around to the people around me and
I'd say come on let's go and I'd say no
no you can't go because we got to do all
these things and you know we can we're
not prepared we're not this we're not
that you know it'll be a hundred you
know objections to this thing I say
don't worry someone will take care of it
let's go and we kind of head off for the
next for the next man and it is the way
you know that is a metaphor of what I
experienced in building this company
yeah there's always kind of reasons not
to do things but it's more important to
actually go do things and I always found
that there were people that would go
clean up after us you know and gonna go
take everything and make it work
correctly and stuff like that and not in
a casual not not in a Cavalier way not
you know not not the leaving messes
behind you an IPO which in this valley
is always thought of as the end point
is not the end point it's not a harvest
it's simply one step on the long road
the real value of companies is built
after the after the IPO so Veritas when
it was an IPO was a 64 million dollar
company at the height of the bubble it
was a 64 billion dollar company we can
increase the value a thousandfold
after the after the IPO and it ended up
getting sell sold to Symantec number
years later at 13 and a half billion
dollar company this huge amount of
social regardless of you know kind of
the top on the bottom of the value of
the company huge amount of value is
built after the IPO the IPO was just
like a little stepping stone and I
remember when we had our IPO I called
all the employees together and I said
it's like college graduation it's called
commencement it's the beginning of the
opportunity to build a great company not
not the end of not the end of the last
accomplishment the last kind of notation
here on advice as a leader it comes from
Harry Truman if you want a friend buy a
dog
here's a picture of my dog Roxie she's a
little older now but pretty much the
same personality and last you know this
is kind of values culture or things of
that nature I think that building a
company with great culture and great
values is what it's all about I think
it's what makes things worthwhile we
spend more time at work than we do with
any other single task in our life and
any other single activity in our life do
the math how much time you spend you
with wife how much time you spend with
your children how much time you spend
with your best you know your best hobby
with your sports whatever it is you
spend more time working and you know
when you're the CEO of a company you
only work you know and it's a it's
unfortunate but there are no such thing
as vacations there's only working in
different places but it never leaves
your mind right so it the place you work
we spend more time at that activity than
anything else in our life since the
outcome of the efforts is not
predictable the quality of the daily
experience is very important you can't
say it's all about you know only the
goal it's also got to be about how we
get there it's not that the you know the
means
justify the end the means have virtue of
their in their own right
values and culture define the character
of the company they permit us to do our
work with integrity to conduct business
in the civilized honest environment and
to do it attend to recruit the best and
the brightest and the principled around
us and I like to work in an environment
like that I'd like to work in a company
where I walk in and I like the quality
of people in those companies I believe
profoundly that they on the contrary do
not only do not SAP the competitive as a
company I think they make companies more
robust and more enduring and more
competitive over time